do that quest where we get Lily than I
can as a not you know and what is that
an anus do as I command him okay I
assume this is a funny i can i can have
varying degrees of mentally i'm
currently investigating the local I've
also gotten my hands on a working
stealth boy marked I think the how not
convinced that the Night Stalker
mutation is a natural one some of the
super mutants have looked around as well
but Lily might be interested in coming
with you she's okay and let's do it
guess who I saw today that's second
there that's let s like in there the
Duchess okay where's lolly well I are
you hey she is there she is hello again
yeah excellent well god i think is cuter
dr. Klein we're dr. burroughs dr.
clients it like a million times okay
let's see how far we got I got to this
pitch popped off [ __ ] why did you like
10,000 feet away at the [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] up okay I got wretches
okay I got [ __ ] that's why this I and
yes think I'm ogun de lis make penis I
Incan dandle I can then don't I hate it
out let's goes batshit crazy I'm gonna
there's a liar where is the lair I'm
here for the lair
and Patrick the lid the lid now okay be
honest I ok not shutting that I gotta
get gone without the lid oh [ __ ] that's
a [ __ ] pop one second i do it safe
all right i know a lot of you i like yes
i got like like why do you gotta dance
classes like he could be playing I don't
like I nade the dancing to fight a mate
okay like it's simple as that everything
video comes to either dancing or mating
and dancing honestly just goes to mating
so like you know what I'm saying like
it's like I could do this roommates or I
could also do some dancing for more
mates you know so I in a hi guys you
know I guess okay let's see let's see
what's in a little school right here
nah [ __ ] howdy friend
yeah oh [ __ ] right did I say wrong
[ __ ] class oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
embarrassing that is [ __ ]
embarrassing oh I was like what the [ __ ]
ok ok a little backtracking sorry guys
all right [ __ ] apologize what [ __ ]
mardia what well if I wonder like what
like she's devil to me she's like yeah
like today I'll ok so the guy did not
want to get exit his house and walk over
a couple steps because that was too much
work I get it I get it you know am I
happy now but you know I get it just
[ __ ] a bulge it but I had to walk
around the whole [ __ ] ok right this is
some [ __ ] this is some [ __ ] this is
like honestly some [ __ ] I paid too
much [ __ ] money where this game and
it's a walking simulator you know like
ah and I like where's the day since a
time where I you know like high sky
hello all right let's do this like ya
thank ya thank you ok about my mate just
gone around here like shut
I think it in case of the sniffles you
know not enough vaya ground hold too
much on you know coffee so nothing
that's how you know how my life is going
you know at lolly k pop a [ __ ]
neanderthal how can and earth all are we
gonna rise island i mean i have a
general idea but I think you would know
better that I so why am i letting you
you know oh Jesus crikey crikey okay
Lily the name of the game is please do
not die cuz i need you and adi da [ __ ]
fire my god okay okay i see i see an end
to the tunnel police nor back there you
look [ __ ] awake now shut all right
let's like the night club like in the
club
let's just make this quick okay like 90
had a gala ramp no more medicine so sad
tough oh what's up [ __ ] yeah that's kind
of [ __ ] up but alright time to fight
hey what
I'm not crap out okay okay let's just
keep moving okay think not like everyone
happy ok bad guys dealt with damn
straight it's our great this one I'm
gonna shoot a dog that's all right
what's that all
okay let's get the [ __ ] out of here I
bet okay anything this way everything is
good nothing to worry about no cause for
an alarm you know Sarah [ __ ] oysters
like a [ __ ] thing like um yeah
Pokemon when you're in a cave you can
just press it like a emergency rope to
get out real quick and was just [ __ ]
like that I don't know our exit now of
course not of course not so let's just
Dave as long as fat yes very beautiful
but kind of long yeah I met game
designers you gotta admit it's kind of
long just utiful path
now it's bad luck that I'd sleep into
the ship go [ __ ] Hotel Aztecs alright
yeah ok ok ok yes I'd like the traveler
ok um now we just walk some more it's
the walk-in quest guys this is a walking
quest
well when is that no okay she just fight
everyone here
hey something else I can do for you yeah
hmm there's still power but the casing
is more important there's only one
having you left for me lily is eccentric
certainly but I've never felt she was
dangerous more important I've told her
about it possibly immediate and
permanent met Lilly already has a freak
Lily yeah i think the talk to you early
oh you're sucking crazy of course Terry
I know what state ah shut
the equipment is hooked up and ready
very well click all right power on the
stealth coil early feel strange strange
my god that casting try thinking
aggressive thoughts now think about
smashing a rat's gone yeah how were
those readings looking calamity still
feel the stable and the readings are
clean hmm gamma wave activity is 0 God
could everything looks right all right
we're done here go ahead and power the
stealth boy down really oh I'll get back
to you on that in a moment once I've
analyzed the result the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] has gone on here well well
congratulations on getting a mark to
prototype functional doctor now just
hand it over and we'll be on our way
what [ __ ] my request is perfectly
reasonable give us the stealth book no I
didn't not until now howdy nice work
with the night kin I've never I got a
lot of useful data from the extra it's
occurred to me that this brief test
might not
that's brilliant